ladies and gentlemen this is gonna be a
series video now we do these every now
and then uh because
not every video has to be a ted talk but
every now and then it's nice to leave
the memes at the door and just go more
with hard facts and statistics
because you know one thing i've noticed
about entrepreneurship finance all these
things
there's a lot of uh really popular
myths that always get spread around and
the way to get past those is usually
with statistics you know i did this with
the trending tab back in the day
you know people are so um superstitious
about what's on youtube trending
and so we just collected the data and we
found out what's actually on it and we
found some really interesting things
and i want to do the same thing here
today i think you can do the same thing
any
in any part of life just look what are
the statistics say
about that thing and today i want to
talk to you guys about um
our entrepreneurs and specifically one
of the greatest questions of all time
she's like
how old are successful entrepreneurs
there's this really common thought
going around you've seen it everywhere
not only on the show
but even uh more perniciously in popular
media that
the young founder well they're
successful but all uh
innovative founders they're young man
they're
they're teenagers they're high school
dropouts or college dropouts or they're
in their 20s you know it's people like
this
you know there are remarkable versions
of this which is like self-made
millionaire at 20 a global group of
enterprises you've seen a lot of this on
this show
you know you have the ceo of teenage
money you have people like this taking
advantage of this
preconceived notion you have the teen
executive you guys have seen this guy
there's so much money cryptocurrency may
be in the last
so how much i made off crypto in 30 days
but there's also just like more explicit
examples of this
in mainstream culture things like the
social network where they we follow mark
zuckerberg
you know this celebrated young founder
from college
and this is what a lot of people uh
think of when they think of
a successful silicon valley founder
someone who's gonna
change the world they're thinking of
someone in their 20s
maybe 30s but that's basically it
and because of this we've had some con
men crop up and grain
gain credibility because honestly you
know like people
expect this is the look they think this
is the look of the young
or uh the successful founder they think
it's people who look like
stefan keane right he's a ponzi scheme
artist who's now
gonna be in jail uh they think it looks
like this
uh elizabeth holmes you guys all
remember her and i would contend across
entrepreneurship widely there's just
this idea
that you know if you want to be an
entrepreneur you have to rush you have
to hurry you have to
maybe not maybe skip college or if you
go to college you have to start a
company right after college
right if you haven't could have any
chance of being a unicorn
uh you know a billion dollar company if
you're going to have any chance
of making something of yourself there's
this huge rush
and this is played off of in popular
culture in what we see
in these like get rich quick schemes and
what we see from you know confidence
confidence artists and even what we see
in media
right you have all the 30 under 30s like
these are the
boldest young entrepreneurs you didn't
need to know in 2019 and it's just a
bunch of like
super young people this is what we think
of is what's shown to us
for what founders act like look like
whatever
basically none of this is true in the
data the young founder
is kind of a myth especially the young
successful founder
so this is a study by harvard uh they
did this in 2018.
great read i'll link it in the show
notes but they found that the actual age
the average age of a
successful startup founder is actually
45.
yes actually it's perpetuated across all
these media companies
that uh the young age is these people
are actually young like
the average tech crunch award is given
to someone who's 31 the average age of
inc magazine is 29 so we're showing only
the young entrepreneurs
but in actual fact the average age of
startup founders is overwhelmingly not
only in the 40s
but if you look at the highest growth
startups meaning the ones that
actually made the difference who
actually got past that hurdle and
they're the top
one percent of companies so they're
doing well
overwhelmingly they're founded by older
guys
so that means again if you account for
the fact that just more people are
starting companies when they're 40 then
when they're 20.
you also have to account for the fact
that they're also more successful than
their younger counterparts
and this makes sense by the way because
of course
more experience makes you more likely to
be successful that's true
across the board with all skills the
older you get the better you tend to get
so
why do we not believe this about
entrepreneurship when you go when you
track how likely someone is to succeed
their likelihood of success with their
company spikes in their 40s and my point
here is not to dissuade you from
starting a company
that's not it at all it's to say guys
you you can take your time
you can have patience entrepreneurship
is a long-term game
and if you go by the media it looks like
something that you can only be a part of
when you're under 30
right and if you don't participate under
30 there's no chance you'll be
successful and of course
the numbers show the exact opposite the
more experience you get
in a field the more likely you're gonna
have to uh have a successful company in
the field because you'll know more about
it
if you go work a job in an industry for
20 years and then go start a company
relative you know relevant to that
industry of course you're going to be
more likely to be successful but that's
not what we see in mainstream media
and not only that it seems that even the
people who invest
in these young founders also are sort of
confused about this stuff paul graham
the founder of y combinator
once quipped that the cutoff for young
inve for in investors heads
is 32 after 32 they start to be a little
skeptical
so it's not just like entrepreneurs that
have this you know thought in their head
it's not just young entrepreneurs
it's even the investors themselves are
sort of confused about what makes
someone successful
everyone's sort of been led away he pied
pipered away from the truth
by this you know silicon valley fantasy
that the young founders the guys are
gonna
revolutionize the world are all these
young dudes that actually we find out
that's completely false even
in software by the way like the silicon
valley thing the average age is still
40 years old okay even in a place where
it's like yeah it's mostly
you know the young people are known to
you know be more likely to
do startups in that field no it's still
40. uh and they're saying that in oil
and gas and biotech the
average age is closer to 47. the point
is not the specifics the point i'm not
saying like hey don't start a company
until you're 40 you're
you know you're 30 whatever what i'm
saying is you have
time and you have to push back against
these not only the con men
who are telling you that oh i'm you know
successful when i'm 20 years old that's
probably not true
but also the fact that even these
companies who are entrepreneurship
magazines or whatever are presenting you
a picture of entrepreneurship
that is also just completely wrong i
think this sentence sums up the
contradictory nature of this whole thing
uh best if you're faced with two
entrepreneurs and know
nothing about them besides their age you
would do better on average
by betting on the older one and yet i
bet if you gave that to a bunch of vcs
they would probably pick the younger one
now the last interesting thing from this
article
that i want to highlight here is uh they
talk about you know the obvious
outliers of these young guys who we've
lionized like bill gates steve jobs all
these guys
and basically what they say is that
while it's true they started their
companies young
when you actually look at where they
made the most impact how old they were
when they made their
most cutting edge innovation it turns
out they're actually
we were very likely to be quite old
steve jobs made the iphone when he was
52
they're talking about like you know the
amazon's biggest growth came when bezos
was 45.
the point is is that even among people
who were entrepreneurs young
they actually also just get better over
time because
of course they do this makes sense
intuitively when you think about it
but if you just kind of unquestionably
going go with the narrative you're going
to be
thinking that young founders you know
are just getting outside of college and
reinventing the world that's not the way
the world works so what does this mean
for you
if you're someone who wants to go into
entrepreneurship
well it just means that you can relax
you can take your time
to sharpen your tools to work a job
where you might get some experience
or you can take your time and realize
that most people don't succeed
in entrepreneurship until later in life
and really
understand that that gives you breathing
room this isn't to
insult young founders this is to say
that
hey you don't have to reinvent all of
humanity by the time you're
29 you don't there's no magical cutoff
where we say you can't be you're
disqualified from being a great
entrepreneur because now
you turn 30. in fact quite the opposite
is true so to all of you guys out there
uh who are entrepreneurs i hope you
learned something to those of you who
are not i hope you also took something
away
thanks for watching a serious video of
coffeezilla
we don't do this too often but let me
know what you thought of my ted talk
thanks for watching and i'll see you
guys next time
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee